all right we are dealing with just a
little bit of crazy to close out the
year the last hatred mail of the year is
a doozy quick reminder about what hatred
mail is a fine Rand and Ronald Reagan
had a baby and suckled that child off
the teat of Liberty its cries would
sound a little something like Patriot
man written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America because freedom
all right so let's get right into this
week's hatred mail a day early because
we are off on January 1st for the New
Year's Day holiday patriot mail this guy
giving us really a lot of material to
work with here what a joke
his is obvious 750,000 subscribers we
know all about that
David betta Pakman you don't know [ __ ]
boy why don't you leave this to the
professionals if we ever need a report
on how to be a [ __ ] we'll let you know
peple you want to see a week desperate
man look no further than this guy king
chuck david pacman 750,000 no no my
friend were at close to seven hundred
and ninety thousand YouTube subscribers
and I will say onward and upward into
2020 with 1 million subscribers being
the target it's been truly an incredible
year in hate reott ISM and sadly and you
know we we joke around about the hate
mail that we get and we sometimes wonder
aloud how it is that people end up being
in a position in their lives where they
choose to write into a show like this
one with this type of hatred and vitriol
but this stuff translates to the real
world and not to turn this into a very
special episode of hatred mail but I
unfortunately expect that this is going
to get worse in 2020 with it being an
election year but we will be here and we
will continue doing everything we can to
put out what we believe
is a perspective that will improve the
country where we're looking to build
things and to do things rather than to
tear down which is much of what we see
as a theme in hatred mail we laugh about
it but that is a theme tearing down
things that people they're trying to do